it's taken 24 hours for the floods
around manville to recede
at first glance a place like this
doesn't look too bad but it's deceptive
the mud is the only sign that all this
was metres under water physically
financially psychologically this extreme
weather is testing communities and
families
like the shahs their home and their
business destroyed
that's my limo business car that's fine
limo business you can see that has the
new york plates on it and i was i
couldn't do anything about it because it
was almost like four feet water by the
course
we were just stuck in strand here we
couldn't able to see that window
yesterday
that window up there yeah the water was
that high you go inside you'll see four
feet water inside we're standing like 15
feet down right now
after you
it's young murid shah who wants to show
us inside it's like old trash everywhere
you can see the sofas
everything the family only moved here
eight months ago and now it's all gone
as you'd expect the small town spirit
here is strong i feel they we have a
responsibility as a as a community and
one
is better than the other no one can be
better than other if you see another
person being affected so i just realized
that walmart was closed so i stopped in
edison and
fill up the
the car with water
our family friend the mother and her
daughter
house completely to the roof submerged
step standing wow everything i mean
between all the explosions i mean i even
felt my own house shake explosions yeah
there was a couple house explosions
sure enough around the corner two of a
number of houses that were leveled the
floods caused electric and gas
explosions thankfully everyone here
evacuated
this small new jersey community was
right underneath ida as it swept north
dumping record rains as it went
every house block after block was
flooded
up the road is mercaro's ironworks
family run for two generations a fencing
company that's now ruined the whole
business everybody we got over 80
employees over here you know
so
i don't know just devastated is anything
salvageable no just memories that's it's
all you're going to save now
inside it's obvious that they will have
to start again
everybody it's open five out of six and
a family five people work over you
but as you say you built it up once you
can do it again we can do it again
that's right again
we're going to do it again yeah i wish
you good luck thank you
back outside the shah's house muhid
wanted the final word
i feel very sad for my grandparents i
really wish i can buy them a new one but
i don't have any money mark stone sky
news in new jersey